>>Chet Haase: So just a reminder this talk
is being live streamed so if you would like
to catch Glenn and Rafe's excellent performance
you can go to that one and then watch ours
at the same time.
Last year we gave a talk where we introduced
Android Jelly Bean 4.1, and 4.2 came out soon
after that.
And today we would like to announce --
>>Romain Guy: Graphics and performance.
[ Laughter ]
>>Romain Guy: The joke would have worked a
lot better, but for some reason for the live
stream we have to show the title slide first
so we have to go back.
Hi, I'm Romain Guy and this is Chet Haase
and we both work on the Android framework
team and we both work on graphics, performance
and animations.
So this talk is divided into three, sections.
First we'll talk about architecture and -- I'll
get back to this.
Then we'll talk about tools and finally we'll
give you some tips and tricks on how to improve
performance on your applications.
The architecture section is interesting because
for the first time I think ever we're going
to talk about stuff that doesn't exist yet.
We're going to talk about stuff that's coming.
So --
>>Chet Haase: It's a really good way for us
not to be here next year to give any talk
to you on behalf of Google, but we're going
to try it anyway.
>>Romain Guy: That doesn't mean it's going
to come out this year or next year.
We can't tell you when, we can't tell you
how and we can't tell you what version number,
what name.
It's just coming sometime in the future.
>>Chet Haase: Maybe.
>>Romain Guy: Hopefully.
>>Chet Haase: So first of all, one of the
architectural changes that we have implemented
in this fictional future release is reordering
and merging.
If you recall last year if you happened to
be in a session called for better or worse,
we gave a really confusing diagram of what's
actually going on in the rendering engine,
and it bottoms out in something we call display
list which is basically our intermediate mode
of the commands that we're going to send down
to the GPU.
Then we compose OpenGL commands out of that
and send them on down and they get rendered,
hardware, acceleration.
Life is good.
What we have done recently is implemented
some changes so that we can actually re-order
and merge commands to make it more optimal
the way that we actually talk to the GPU.
We have in previous talks and in articles
recommended a tip where you should batch your
commands.
So if you're doing a bunch of -- like I'm
going to draw a bitmap, I'm going to draw
some text, I'm going to draw a bitmap, draw
some text, it's better for us and for the
GPU if you draw all the bitmaps at once and
all the text at once.
We've tried to remove that from you and just
do it more automatically.
In fact, it turns out that we can actually
do even better than that.
>>Romain Guy: For once we're making your life
easier instead of harder.
>>Chet Haase: I don't know how that happened.
>>Romain Guy: It is not even an API.
It's all automatic.
>>Chet Haase: So let's pretend that this is
a sample UI, a very boring sample UI, but
an sample UI nonetheless.
We have a couple of chat boxes, each one with
some text.
We have a couple of buttons.
Let's pretend the order that we see it on
the screen is the order in which they're added
to the containers, so they're basically going
to draw it in this order.
So we're going to -- there's the order.
We're going to draw the check boxes, so we
draw a bitmap with the checked check box,
and then we're going to draw --
>>Romain Guy: [ Inaudible ]
>>Chet Haase: That animation was so awesome
we're going to do it again.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chet Haase: Draw a bitmap, we're going to
draw some text, we're going to draw a bitmap,
draw some text, we're going to draw a nine
patch and draw some text.
Eight commands, not a lot to worry about,
but let's see what happens when we can actually
re-order these things.
So we can switch things around so that before
we send it down to the GPU in the display
list itself we switch the order of commands
so you draw a bitmap twice, draw two nine
patches and then draw the text that are next
to and on top of those objects.
That tends to be a lot faster for the GPU
to process because it doesn't have to change
state.
It's not constantly changing the state of
the shaders that it's using, the state that
we draw bitmaps with versus the state of text.
None of those things have to change and the
GPU is really happy when you don't change
states.
So this is a good step to begin with and this
is where you could get to if you manually
batched your stuff according to when you made
your drawing step.
We can do that for you now in this fictional
upcoming release.
But on top of that we could do something that
we call merging, which is we can actually
take all of those commands that we have now
reordered and say, do you know what?
What if we just did one command that drew
two bitmaps in a row and did one command that
drew to nine patches in a row, and then draw
all of the text all at the same time?
Even though they're actually on different
views on the screen, that's irrelevant to
the GPU.
All it's doing is drawing pixels on the screen.
If we can do that we've reduced essentially
eight commands to the GPU, which were originally
changing state and interweaving it the entire
time into three commands, which is much better
for the GPU and much better for performance
in general.
>>Romain Guy: So we have a demo.
We'll use Google+ as an example and I'm going
to switch to one of our debugging tools.
I'm going to show you what happens when -- without
the reordering and the merging.
So I'll launch that tool to open the debugging
and I'll capture a frame and we'll see exactly
what the app draws.
Are getting everything?
Yes.
So we have to look at in details, but as you
can see this is the G+ UI so you have all
your cards in your stream of posts, and you
can see that we draw the cards one by one
because that's how they're defined.
We'll draw the white backgrounds first and
then Chet's face and then we'll go to the
text and then we go to the next card and we
do that over and over again.
So in total we have 88 drawing commands that
have been executed on this frame.
And as you can see there's a lot of -- Chet
was talking about state changes and you can
see it happening here.
Here we draw a bunch of text, then we switch
to bitmaps, then we draw text again, then
bitmaps again and text and bitmap and so on
and so forth.
So now if we re-enable the new optimizations
-- I have to kill the app first.
Of course, it's reloaded the post so now they
are different.
>>Chet Haase: Tension is building.
What's it going to look like?
>>Romain Guy: What makes me happy is we have
everyone -- people at the conference this
week, so if it insists on not working we can
go yell at them.
>>Chet Haase: Is there a dev doctor in the
house?
>>Romain Guy: So this is what we do everyday
and everyday it's the same.
We have to try again and again and again until
it works.
[ Laughter ]
>>Romain Guy: So you know whenever you complain
about the dev tools just know that we're in
the same boat.
[ Laughter ]
>>Romain Guy: All right.
So we went from 88 drawing commands to 39.
So it's not exactly the same configuration,
but you can see what's going on here.
Things are drawn out of order.
You can see the text appear in pretty much
one block.
We're going to go back to that.
Let's go here at the beginning.
So we can see that we're drawing the white
backgrounds of the cards together and then
we go back to fill the inside of the cards.
And then when we draw the text there's this
one spot where we draw a huge batch of text,
right here.
And you can see the geometry here, you can
see that we draw pretty much the entire text
on screen in one draw call instead of many.
So this is what it does for you.
You don't have to worry about it.
Don't change your app.
It's going to be faster and better automatically.
And in the future version of Android that
may or may not exist, and that you may or
may not get on your device, we are also going
to introduce a little bit of multi-threading
to the rendering pipeline.
So we're still going to do the rendering on
the main thread, so it's still very important
that you do not block the main thread to get
smooth animations; however, some of the operations
that the render performs on your behalf will
now happen on multiple cores, if you have
multiple cores.
>>Chet Haase: Which is more and more common.
The way that manufacturers are scaling performance
in general tends to be going wide, so you've
got as opposed to faster and faster CPUs,
which was the model for year, now we're getting
multiple cores, two cores, four cores.
If you've got these multiple cores down there
can you take advantage of parallel processing
instead of just continuing to do everything
as fast as you can on one.
>>Romain Guy: So here we're executing the
drawing command.
If you're using drop shadows in your application,
if you have drop shadows on text, that's what
the launcher does a lot on Android, we'll
use renderscript and we're going to spin up
on the four core device.
We're going to use four threads to generate
the drop shadows, so we'll use all the cores
at our disposal.
So if you draw a little circles or arbitrary
geometric shapes with curves, we're also going
to use multiple cores to draw this in the
background as open textures so then we can
draw them on the UI thread.
So once again, you don't have anything to
do, this all under the hood, but just be aware
what's going on.
We also have support for non-rectangular clipping.
It wasn't supported in the (Indiscernible)
pipeline, so non-rectangular clipping can
be used to draw very useful things such as
text in the shape of a heart.
If you ever do that in your app, like I don't
want to know what your app does, but you can
also be using -- we'll talk more about -- we
will talk more about that later.
It can also be used to clip when you're doing
rotations.
So let's say you have a ListView or a ScrollView
and you have a 3D rotation so you want to
flip it over.
If you're not using a layer and you run that
animation on existing versions of Android,
like 4.1 or 4.2, you will see that the clipping
breaks because the clip rect of the list as
you rotate it in 3D doesn't -- turns into
something that's not a rectangle any more.
And we didn't know how to deal with that before,
but now that's fixed or it will be fixed.
And if you're curious on how to do a non-rectangular
clipping and want to clip your text with a
heart, this is how you do it.
You get a canvas, you can call clip path.
There are other methods that you can use.
You can do those fancy shapes.
And then you just draw your content and it
will do the right thing for you.
>>Chet Haase: Now a discussion about some
of the tools that we use.
Some of these exist now, but we'll be talking
about some slight modifications and improvements
going forward in possible and fictional releases.
>>Romain Guy: So the first one was introduced
in 4.2, I think.
It's a debug tool that's on the device so
you go to settings, developer options, there's
a check box called show dp overdraw.
I wrote about it online.
I wrote an article about that.
How many of you know about this option or
have used this option?
Why are we here?
[ Laughter ]
>>Romain Guy: You're making my job useless.
So show dp overdraw will colorize the screen,
it will use several different colors to show
you how many times you draw each individual
pixel on the screen.
So here you have a picture of the Google Play
Store with the option turned on, and you can
see there's this bluish tint in the background.
That doesn't come from the app.
That's the tool adding this blue color on
the background.
You can see there's a lot of red in the middle,
the app called 1-800-flowers.
You can see there's a lot of red in the middle
because we have a lot of pixels here.
So the color code is pretty simple.
Blue means you've drawn a 1X overdraw.
So it means that you've drawn that pixel once
and then you've drawn on top of it.
So there's a 1X overdraw.
Green means you have a 2X overview, so you've
drawn the pixel three times.
The slight difference between the two reds.
It doesn't really matter because if it's red
you're doing something wrong.
Red is 3X or 4X or more.
>>Chet Haase: And if it's 5X we just reboot
the machine.
>>Romain Guy: I wish I could do that.
>>Chet Haase: And there is a 0X.
If you actually have no redraw, then you will
just see the natural color that they're painting
on the screen.
>>Romain Guy: We'll see the video of the overdrew
and how it works and the kind of techniques
that you can use to fix overdraw in a few
minutes.
>>Chet Haase: So this is a tool that we introduced
in 4.1.
>>Romain Guy: Last year.
>>Chet Haase: To track your frame rate.
It seemed to be a little bit sort of inconsistent
on how you would get the frame rate and how
to understand how fast you were running and
more importantly how consistently fast you
were running, what your effective frame rate
was in your application.
So we instrumented the system to give you
this information, and if you did an ADB shell
command dump GFX info, then we would spit
out the information for the last 120 frames
and then you could take that data and you
could paste it into a spreadsheet and then
you could create a chart, and apparently that
was too tedious for people.
So we have made that a little bit easier.
Actually, if you go back to the previous slide,
this gives you the information about the time
that we're spending actually creating the
drawing commands that are going to be issued
and then issuing the drawing commands and
then waiting for OpenGL to come back because
it processed the drawing commands and swapped
the buffers.
This gives you an indication of those relative
times as well as how many times that's happening
per second or what your frame rate is.
So we have the same exact tool available now,
but instead of making you go through the incredibly
tedious and overbearing process of creating
a spreadsheet to see a graph, we actually
just create the graph for you on the screen.
So you can pull up developer settings, you
can select an option in the dialogue box to
see how you want to display the information,
whether you want to use the tedious method
or some onscreen graphical method.
Instead, you can see the results in real-time,
such as is demonstrated here.
We're running a calendar application, and
we can see as the calendar application, I
think you were probably scrolling back and
forth in the calendar application.
And you can see in real time us update an
overlay on the device so you can see what
the rendering performance and frame rate is
like.
So you will actually see this for all active
activities on the screen, which is why there's
actually three separate charts that you will
see.
You will see one for calendar, you will also
see one for the navigation bar and the notification
bar at the top.
>>Romain Guy: It works in every application.
And you can see it working here -- right here
on the device in real time.
There's a green line that wasn't shown in
the graph that we used last year as a demonstration.
So the green line is the 16 milliseconds threshold.
So if all your vertical bars are under that
line, then you will run at 60 FPS.
And if you cross that line then there's going
to be jank.
So it's more complicated than that, but basically
if you can stay below the line you're part
-- you're in good shape in your application.
>>Chet Haase: The general tip is smaller is
better.
Try to stay away from the green line on the
underside of it.
And what you will see -- and also be aware
of situations where you're tripping very occasionally
over that green line because then basically
you drop down to half the frame rate immediately
and the net effect on the screen is that the
user is going to see a stuttery animation
where it was smooth in 60 FPS and then you
skipped a frame in the middle.
It's a very discontinuous and disturbing artifact.
[ Applause ]
>>Romain Guy: I have to say, most of the time
when you guys send us emails or ask questions,
you're pretty mad at us.
It's pretty cool when you are happy.
I like that.
Keep doing it.
>>Chet Haase: Maybe it was an angry clap.
>>Romain Guy: Maybe it was an angry clap.
Yeah, I'm worried now.
Next we want to talk about systrace.
Systrace is this awesome tool, and you can
thank Jamie right here for the tool.
It's a great performing tool we introduced
last year.
It was a little difficult to use, just like
the performance graph we showed you.
It was a little bit involved to set it up.
And in this future version of Android -- sorry,
future update of Android, not necessarily
version number, it's easier to use systrace.
So now the way you invoke systrace is still
from the command line, but you had to turn
on several tags.
Like you had to tell us I want to profile
graphics, I want to profile views, I want
to profile the window manager, and then you
had to restart the runtime on the device,
effectively rebooting the device, and then
you could run your command.
Now the way you do it you just invoke the
script, you specify the tags that you want
to trace.
So here we are tracing gfx that's all, that's
all the graphics information; view, that's
all the UI toolkit information; things like
inflation, layout, measure.
Freq is the frequency of the different CPUs,
and sched is the scheduler, so that way you
can see who scheduled on what the CPU and
when.
And I am going to show you and example of
that.
We also added in 4.2 the ability to trace
open OpenGL commands.
So if you use OpenGL in your application and
or if you write a normal application and you
are curious about how many GL commands we
execute on your behalf, you can go turn that
on in the developer options, and we're going
to trace every individual OpenGL command and
you are going to see them in systrace.
Actually, let's go with the slides for a while.
We are also introducing a new API.
So there's this new class called Android.os.trace.
That's the API that we use internally in the
framework to do all of this instrumentation,
but we're opening it up a little bit.
There's this new API called begin section
and end section.
And here, this is an adapter.
It's an adapter I created in a little test
application, and at the beginning I call begin
section.
I specify string.
So that's just the name of the section you're
going to see the in profiler.
So that name can be anything you want.
At the end you close the section by saying
end section, and in the middle we can have
another section called bind.
So you can nest the sections.
The advantage of using this over TraceView
is that the overhead is almost nonexistent.
So it's not going to modify the behavior of
your application when it's running, and the
timing that it gives you are very, very, very
precise.
And if you do this -- so if you use this new
API, you have to use this other flag when
you invoke systrace.
You have to use dash A and you have to enter
the name, the package name of your application.
>>Chet Haase: So to be clear, we're not recommending
don't use TraceView.
TraceView is awesome.
It is the tool to get all the information
on all the method calls that happened.
However, if it's showing you timing about
method call overhead at the Java layer, be
suspicious because there's a lot of overhead
associated with the tool and with the instrumentation
in particular.
So if you want to eliminate that as a factor
and you know the code path that you want to
instrument very carefully, this is a really
good way to get that information.
>>Romain Guy: And very often the way we will
use systrace, at least at our level, we will
use systrace to get an idea of where the application
is slow, and then we have pinpointed that
part of the application then we will use systrace
to see inside that block what is taking time.
This is much more efficient usually than going
to TraceView directly.
So here I have two more examples.
Here is -- Okay.
The first one, so this is what the systrace
file looks like.
It is pretty scary but it is actually pretty
cool.
At the top here you can see three CPUs, and
if I zoom in all the way --
>>Chet Haase: I like the text heart better.
It was more romantic.
>>Romain Guy: So if I zoom in all the way,
it may be hard to see but you can see the
name of the process that was scheduled on
the CPU, on CPU zero at that time.
So if you're doing a lot of multi-threading
in your application, it's a great way to see
what exactly is going on.
So maybe all your threads are running one
after the other because you have a synchronization
issue.
You can see that in systrace.
You can see the frequency of each CPU.
So here the CPU zero and CPU one were running
at full frequency, and you can see that sometimes
they go back down a little bit.
So I took this when I was scrolling -- I don't
remember.
It was Gmail.
And here at the bottom I have the name of
the application cell, so this is Gmail and
we can see what Gmail was doing.
So here we can see one frame of the Gmail
application, and we can see that Gmail took
28 milliseconds to render one frame, so that's
too slow, but only less than one millisecond
was spent on the Dalvik side executing Java
code.
So most of the time is spent executing the
OpenGL commands, so that means that the app
is not doing much at the Java level, but it
gave us so many drawing commands that we cannot
draw at 60 fps.
And I keep zooming here, you can see all the
individual OpenGL commands that we've executed
for you.
So if you work on games, that's probably a
lot more useful than if you work on apps.
But this is what the systrace looks like.
And we should -- there's a lot to do -- to
say about systrace.
We would need a couple hours, I think, to
teach you exactly how it works.
But go give it a try.
It's really cool.
Now, if you use that new API I just mentioned,
the begin and end section, this is what it's
going to look like.
So here you can see the two tags I created.
I know they are hard to read, but you see
the strings create list item and bind image.
I'm trying to zoom.
So again, you can see exactly how much time
you are spending executing the section.
So here, I'm spending 31 milliseconds in GetView,
and out of 31 milliseconds, almost the entire
time was spent binding an image so I was probably
loading the image from the GetView method.
>>Chet Haase: Tips and tricks.
>>Romain Guy: Overdraw then?
>>Chet Haase: Yeah.
>>Romain Guy: So we'll switch to code.
>>Chet Haase: Is this the one you did your
analysis --
>>Romain Guy: No.
It's a different one.
>>Chet Haase: Okay.
>>Romain Guy: So I have a very simple application
that I'm going to install on this phone over
there, and I am using the new Android Studio,
so hopefully it works.
Yeah, it worked.
So this app is just a demo app; right?
So it's a list of images, and what I do is
I fake loading the images from the network,
so when I scroll really quickly, you can see
a placeholder, and after a random amount of
time, the image appears.
So the scrolling is pretty good but this is
a Nexus 4 so performance is usually awesome
on the device.
Now, if we go into settings and we turn on
the overdraw debug -- where is it?
Here we go.
So now everything becomes green and blue and
it's hard to read but you can see my application
is mostly red.
So the background of the app is blue that
means there is something behind the background
of the app so we should get rid of that.
The images are deep red so there is clearly
something else also behind them, and my nine
patches are green so there's, again, something
behind those things.
So now we're going to go to the code and see
what we can do to fix this application.
So if we look at the layout of the activity,
or look at the XML -- how do I zoom?
Here we go.
Is the text big enough for everybody?
Okay.
You can see here I have a simple ListView.
That's all there is in my application.
I have a ListView and I gave it a background
color because I wanted that custom color.
But by default, on Android when you create
and application you have a background already.
It's the window background.
It comes with the theme.
So right now I have two backgrounds.
I have the one that comes from the theme and
the one in my list and we're going to draw
both, and that's where most of the overdraw
comes from.
So instead of setting that background here
on the list, what I could do is remove it
from the list, then go to my style that was
created for me when I created the application,
and you can specify a window background.
And here I'm just going to specify the color
I was using in the ListView.
So now if I run the demo again.
So you can see it's not deep red anymore.
We have this light red on the images, and
the background of the app, it's real hard
to read on the screen perhaps but it's white.
It's not blue anymore.
And the cards themselves, the nine patches
of the cards are not green anymore.
It's blue.
So we lost one layer of overdraw.
But we can be even more (indiscernible) than
that.
So we have all these placeholder images that
we show before we load the real image.
And what's going on is once we have done binding,
loading an image from the network and binding
it on the image view, we're not removing the
placeholder.
So the way to do this is -- I lost my placeholder.
I don't remember how to do it in that demo
but you could just remove -- make sure that
if you have placeholders and you put an image
on top of it, make sure to remove the placeholder.
>>Chet Haase: We're going to leave that as
an exercise to the reader.
>>Romain Guy: It's an exercise to the reader.
[ Laughter ]
>>> (Speaking off microphone.)
>>Romain Guy: Yes.
Don't get ahead.
Also, they can't hear you.
And the last trick you can use and a lot of
applications can benefit from that, so this
is the nine patch I'm using for the cards.
So this is this little -- you know, there
was a little drop shadow and there was this
little white area under the image.
So this is a perfectly regular nine patch.
There's nothing weird about it but as you
can see, the entire inside of the nine patch
-- and let me show you the inside.
Show content.
So the blue area here is where my images will
go.
So that area is a single opaque color.
It's white.
But because we're going to hide it with an
image, there's no reason for that to be drawn.
So instead what you can use is you can modify
your nine patch and it's real hard to read
on screen.
Here you can see under my mask cursor, there's
a single transparent pixel.
So just cut a hole in the nine patch and this
is the area that we stretch.
So here again the blue area on the right,
you can see it's transparent.
So we won't be drawing anything behind the
images anymore.
And the rendering pipeline is smart enough
to recognize there is a hole in the nine patch
the it will remove that part of the geometry
and get rid of the overdraw.
>>Chet Haase: Trilinear filtering is something
we --
>>Romain Guy: 4.2.
>>Chet Haase: Right.
4.2.
So this API actually exists in a release that's
out there right now.
It's also referred to as MIP mapping, sort
of classic, traditional graphics technique
of getting better image filtering when your
down scaling sort of extremely.
If you are going down to more than half the
size, it doesn't really matter that much.
It's not going to change that, but the effect
is if you know that bilinear filtering is
basically sampling the pixels on either side
and top and bottom of the pixel you're going
to fill in and then blending that result,
trilinear filtering is doing the same thing
on the two images that bracket the image size
that you really need, and then filtering that
result as well and you get a much better scaling
result.
For instance, I think we zoom in on these
images.
You can't really tell the difference there.
>>Romain Guy: Go back.
So in this demo, the two images were really
large.
They were bigger than the screen and the same
image was reduced twice on the left and on
the right to less than half its size.
On the left side it was using the normal filtering
and on the right side it's using trilinear
filtering.
>>Chet Haase: So if we zoom up so you can
see the effect a little more clearly, you
can see the one on the right is much smoother.
We're not running into the same artifacts,
the jaggy artifacts that we have on the left
because we're using more information about
all of the MIP levels.
So we can see the -- was there the representation
to MIP map?
Did I go past that one?
Yeah; right.
So (indiscernible) this, this is what MIP
mapping or trilinear filtering actually produces.
Instead of just the one image that we're going
to filter from, we actually produced powers
of two sizes below that.
And then we have all of those choices to then
filter from when we do the MIP mapping.
And there it is again because it's so awesome.
And here is the code.
If you want to do it in code at runtime, set
has MIP map to true, or you can do it in your
XML drawable resource instead with the MIP
map attribute.
>>Romain Guy: We're going to talk about canvas
layers.
So this is the (indiscernible) API on the
canvas class.
So we have two types of layers.
And if you don't write custom code, they don't
really matter to you directly but we see why
they do matter even when you write an application
using only views.
So the first type of layer is what we call
clip layers.
So when you call the save layer method on
the canvas, you can pass a flag at the end
the last parameter, and here we pass the value
clip to layer save flag.
Then we draw stuff.
So what this method does is very simple.
So here we have our canvas.
We invoke save layer.
We're going to create an upscreen bitmap,
so we're basically creating some -- you can
see that as a second canvas.
And then when we draw the contents, or here
we're drawing an image, that image will be
constrained to that new canvas.
So it's not going to bleed out anywhere else,
but we've created a second canvas.
We have the second image in memory.
This is very useful for a number of effects,
especially opacity and we're going to talk
about that.
If you have save layer and you pass zero as
the flag at the end, you're creating an unclipped
layer.
And unclipped layers are extremely expensive
because when you invoke them, the save layer
method, we still have to create that extra
buffer in memory.
But every time you draw something, what you're
drawing is going to be drawn on every layer
that the parameter you're drawing with intersects.
So if you create end layers and the parameters
you're drawing, your bitmap, intersects all
of them, we're going to execute the command
end times.
So that can be extremely expensive.
So this is what we do in software.
In hardware we do it a little differently
but it's also extremely expensive, and I think
we give details in one of our talks.
I think maybe at Devoxx at the end of 2012,
we explained exactly what happens in hardware.
But the point is if you're using save layer,
be very careful because either in software
or in hardware the results can be pretty bad
for your performance.
And if you remember, on Android we used to
have those fading edges in lists and all scroll
views all over the place, and that's how the
filling edges are implemented.
They use the save layer commands.
So the top and bottom edges are one save layer
each, and they were really expensive to run
and also they didn't fit the new Ice Cream
Sandwich themes so we got rid of them.
>>Chet Haase: Let's talk about alpha.
So alpha is a cool property on view.
You can make views translucent with alpha.
It's very handy for fading views in and out
and it's really, really easy with alpha to
give yourself performance problems that you
really don't need to be suffering from.
So the general tip is use it, but be aware
of what you're doing and maybe there's a better
way to actually get the effect that you're
looking for.
So there's lots of different ways to tie yourself
in knots with alpha.
You can set the alpha on a view, in a couple
of different ways.
You can create an animation, object animator
or view property animator that evaluate alpha
over time or you can use one of the old style
alpha animations.
These all end up doing the same thing under
the hood, which is essentially creating an
alpha layer, just like Romain already talked
about.
So we're going to create these intermediate
buffers, we're going to draw stuff there,
we're going to copy it back and composite
it.
A fair amount of work to go through, which
is fine if that's what you need.
But in a lot of situations, that's actually
not what you need.
You just didn't know there were alternatives,
so maybe it would be good to find out what
the alternatives are.
It's also good to understand why you actually
care about this.
You might think, well, I've got this view
and it's drawing several things.
Why don't you just draw each one of these
things with alpha directly into the screen
as opposed to creating this separate buffer
over here, drawing everything and then compositing
it back.
So there's a handy animation here to see what
kind of effect you're going to get if you're
just going to draw things with alpha directly
to the screen, if we wanted to draw all of
these images and then show a translucent view
of the images, if we drew the images separately
with alpha, this is what you get, which in
graphics is called a mess.
And what you actually wanted was something
more like this; right?
We just wanted to fade everything when it
was drawn together, not fade the individual
items so that they all mushed together into
that mess.
So what are some of the alternatives?
So here's one.
This is a simple one.
We ran into this one in notification panel,
which won't be named.
>>Romain Guy: It was Dr. Dan's fault.
>>Chet Haase: It was Dr. Dan's fault, actually.
So the engineer who was playing with this
was trying to achieve a particular effect,
a specific color.
It was basically a 70% translucent white value;
right?
Gave this nice gray, which is wonderful, except
what ended up happening was alpha was set
on the text view, and the text view occupied
most of the notification panel item, and there
were several items on the screen and you got
a significant performance problem because
of that.
We were basically drawing most of the screen
into these separate off-screen buffers and
compositing back all so that we could have
gray text on the screen.
The correct solution for that particular egregious
performance problem was to use gray text.
[ Laughter ]
>>Chet Haase: A slightly more direct or alternative
way is if you really want alpha to achieve
the exact color you're going for, if you're
animating the translucency of that text, you
can set alpha directly on the text color itself
and we're going to draw that much more optimally
than using the separate buffer approach.
Image view, similarly, you can set the image
alpha.
This was new API in ICS.
>>Romain Guy: Jelly Bean.
>>Chet Haase: Jelly Bean?
>>Romain Guy: Yes.
>>Chet Haase: Okay.
4.1.
You can set the image alpha and then when
we draw the image of that image view, we will
use that alpha.
Again, we're drawing directly into the destination
buffer as opposed to creating this set-aside
buffer that we then composite from.
Much faster if that's the effect that you're
looking for.
If you have a custom view and you know that
you're going to draw all these different operations
and you're happy to draw them translucently,
then you can actually change the alpha on
the paint and draw directly into the destination
instead of setting the alpha directly on the
view itself.
Again, you know what you're view is doing,
so do the right thing for your situation.
Don't depend on, you know, framework capabilities
that are a bit more generic but from which
you might suffer because we can't know whether
you're going to run into some of the artifacts
that we talked about.
Or you can set a layer.
This is kind of a good thing to do in general,
especially for animations.
If it's a complex view and you want to fade
the view, just set a hardware layer on the
object during the animation, and then when
you do an alpha fade on that, if you set the
alpha property or animate the alpha property,
then we can take care of that very fast.
We create a texture map and we just fade the
alpha on that texture directly.
And another related thing to mention is this
new method that was introduced probably in
API level 16, which is has overlapping rendering.
We like method names that are really long,
preferably if they actually go past the character
wrap at the end of the screen.
This one didn't quite make it.
This one we use under the hood to figure out
if we can draw optimally in this view.
If there is no overlapping rendering in a
view, we know we can draw each rendering operation
separately with alpha, and we'll take care
of that very optimally, as opposed to you
know we don't know whether these rendering
operation overlap or not so we'll just draw
them all into the buffer and then composite
them back.
So if you have a custom view, you can consider
overriding this method and telling us that
you do not have overlapping rendering, and
we're going to be able to handle alpha operations
faster.
>>Romain Guy: We have only five minutes left
so we're going to start talking a little faster.
Now let's talk about canvas.
Here is an issue I see in a lot of applications
and I see a lot of confused people online
asking about this behavior.
So imagine you have a canvas and that canvas
is 640 pixels wide, 400 pixels high and you
call canvas that get width and canvas that
get height.
So I see people think it's going to give them
the size of the window, I see people who think
it's going to give them the size of the view,
and the answer is both.
So if we have this canvas in a window, let's
say you're on a Nexus 4 or Nexus 7 and the
window is about 1280 pixels by 800 and inside
you have a view that's 600 by 300, and you
call get width and get height, in the window
you're going to get the size of the view as
the answer.
So you call canvas that get width and canvas
that get height and you're getting the size
of the view.
In software, you're going to get the size
of the window.
The point here is do not use the dimensions
of the canvas as the dimensions of your view.
You can just use view the get width and view
the get height.
There's no reason why you should use the width
and height of the canvas pretty much ever
and you can think about it in a different
way.
If you were to rely on one of those two values
to be exact, what would happen if instead
of giving you the canvas of the window we
would give you the canvas of a bitmap, because
we're taking a screen shot or we're taking
a drawing cache.
Then you would get a completely arbitrary
value.
So be very careful if you're using those methods
your code.
Now let's talk a little bit about clipping.
I mentioned that we're introducing super (indiscernible)
clipping, so if you're doing rotations and
clipping, be very careful about the order
of operations.
So here, for instance, we're simply going
to draw a rotated bitmap and we want to clip
that bitmap just in case.
So we first clip with a rectangle, then we
rotate by minus 30 degrees, then draw the
bitmap.
So this is what's going to happen.
You have your canvas.
We apply the clip rect, then we rotate the
canvas, we draw our bitmap and this is the
result.
As you can see the clip rect remained a rectangle
throughout the drawing operations.
So we can do it very efficiently.
Now, if you do it the other way around, if
you rotate first, then use your clip rect
and then you draw, here's what's going to
happen.
We're going to rotate the canvas, we're going
to apply the clip rect, we're going to draw,
and the result is the same because we're not
intersecting -- we're not going outside of
the bounds of the clip rect.
But now that we are back nonrotated, you can
see that our rectangle is not a rectangle
anymore.
It's actually some sort of a diamond.
So to apply this affect, what we have to do
under the hood is we have to use something
on the GPU called the stencil buffer, it's
some sort of a mask, we have to clear that
mask, we have to render the rotated rectangle
that (indiscernible) the clip inside it, and
then when we draw the bitmap, for each pixel
we have to test the pixel of the bitmap against
the content of the stencil buffer.
GPUs are very good at doing that kind of stuff,
so if you do it once per frame, it's okay,
but if you have a lot of very expensive drawing
commands or if you change the clip rect or
if you keep rotating in different ways, it's
going to be extremely expensive.
And again, remember that you can end up with
a nonrectanglar clip that is just setting
a rotation on the view if you do a 3D flip
or just a rotation on the Z axis.
Let's imagine you have a view that's 640 pixels
wide by 400 pixels high, and we invalidate
a small region of the view.
So we co-invalidate, we specify this little
rectangle here inside, and we ask for the
clip bounds on the canvas in the draw method.
The clip bounds are going to be different
if you are hardware accelerated or if you
are not.
So with hardware acceleration, the clip bounds
will always be the size of the view because
we record a (indiscernible).
So the clip bounds don't matter at record
time.
We just want to see all the drawing comments
that you want to execute.
When we're going to replay the display list,
then we're going to apply the dirty bounds.
In software, however, we're going to give
you the exact clip bounds that you set using
invalidate.
>>Chet Haase: We are not going to talk about
reordering barriers.
We will be posting these slides online.
That is, in fact, the talk.
There's some links to other information on
related topics.
Parleys.com has a lot of recorded talks that
you can watch.
And there were performance case studies you
can check out online.
Our blogs post all of this kind of information,
or watch us on G+ where we also talk about
this stuff.
Thank you.